non monsieur la seule vous avez la
parole sur l'article 8 quater et merci
beaucoup madame la présidente je suis le
ministre
d'abord je voudrais dire que nous avons
beaucoup de chance de vous avoir comme
présidente parce que vous êtes d'une
rigueur remarquable donner la parole
plusieurs fois alors que ce n'est pas le
cas de tous vos collègues et en même
temps vous êtes d'une humanité
rassurantes donc je voulais vous le dire
non merci
c'est très bien car je vous le dis bon
vieux temps que j'y suis je veux faire
de jaloux quant à monsieur m'a quand il
était à la tête du gouvernement lorsque
monsieur val sera privé de valls qui va
prendre dans l'année à venir
enfin bref vous m'avez compris mais vous
êtes en très net progrès monsieur macron
vous aussi ceci étant comme j'ai vu que
j'étais un des rares à avoir connu
finalement cette épreuve redoutable de
devoir repasser mon termine deuxième
fois est presque une troisième
parce que vous savez le souhaitent
députés que vous n'avez pas de chauffeur
les points cet homme très vite tous très
très vite et donc j'ai vu et je suis
très heureux
comme l'a dit andré collègues que nous
puissions avoir ce soir cette discussion
que je n'aurais pas imaginé à
l'assemblée tellement je pensais que le
sujet était devenu tabou et que
effectivement les progrès dont nous ne
pouvons tous que nous réjouir nous
réjouir de nombre de tués sur la route
avait dix ont passé tout le reste au
second plan eh bien oui madame la
présidente
nous avons des centaines des dizaines de
milliers de français qui n'ont des tests
au point vous ne pouvez pas imaginer sur
les dispositions prises sur le plan de
retrait de permis de conduire alors je
ne vais pas en rajouter beaucoup parce
que je fréquentais a été excellente
mais vous pêle-mêle les stages sont
chères savez pour une famille qui n'a
pas beaucoup de travail tout le monde
n'est pas député parmi ceux qui perdent
leur coeur
de conduire dungy nana qui n'ont pas le
même revenu même si le mien est assez
moyen enfants mais au fond un site
le nombre de leçons ça se tire ça c'est
dire
et ça finit par coûter très cher et
c'est très long et puis la suit vous
passer le permis de conduire comme c'est
le cas chez moi c'est au bout de 30 mois
mais trente mois c'est assez lent et je
peux vous dire je voudrais prendre
l'avion ce matin à 4 heures du matin
avec un voisin qui vient vous amener
eller qui vous recherchez dans la dans
leur fameux vient vous chercher
trois jours après à 11 heures et demie
du soir c'est long mais pour nos
compatriotes c'est très long aussi alors
quand enfin vous avez fait de 30 mois et
bien vous n'avez pas forcément à passer
la conduite mais vous passer des tests
psychotechniques je peux vous le dire
parce que jenny perdu j'ai dû me repas
nos trois fois le problème c'est pas que
j'étais mauvais bien que le premier test
psychotechnique que j'ai passées à
l'école à l'âge de huit ans alors que
j'étais en france et 3eme lang avait
révélé que j'avais un cuit juste au
dessus très légèrement de 0 mais en
faire là j'avais une dame mais c'est
très sérieux au centre hospitalier de
pau mamie de machines aux mains comme
mes enfants lorsqu'ils jouent à la
playstation sauver avec un écran de
télévision
et il s'agissait d' arrêter une bulle
qui ne devait pas franchir l'écran de
manière latérale et vient j'appuyais sur
la manette gauche sur la manette droite
des fois sur les deux
mais à chaque fois la balle allait
s'écraser wamba mais n'allez jamais de
bout en bout donc la dame s'est mise
dans une colère impitoyable et a décrété
que je m'étais moquer d'elle et à
retarder tout de trois mois l'échéance à
laquelle je devais repasser mon père ly
dont finalement au bout d'un an après
les trente mois non mes amis je pensais
pas qu'on pouvait le dire voyez jugé lit
madame cruise et y rassurante mais il
faut l'expliquer parce que si on
n'explique pas si un député de la nation
n'explique pas à partir de son
expérience ce que vivent ses concitoyens
mais qui le fera moi je l' ai vécu donc
que finalement j'ai réussi par la voix
et ensuite il faut avoir le corps mais
alors le code quand vous aurez 60h ce
qui va être le cas dans quelques
semaines pour moi madame mais avec c'est
pas facile non plus il faut beaucoup
s'entraîner bon heureusement il ya un
site je le signale sur internet qui
quand même vous donner des leçons
profitable dont je suis très heureux je
n'ose hier cette discussion
bien sûr j'étais un petit peu égayer
j'en ai conscience il faut des fois être
un petit peu dans l'humour parce qu'on
fait passer des choses qui sont
difficiles mais c'est très lourd et je
suis très heureux que la représentation
française au ceram de compte à quel
point le problème est dur et très
durement vécue merci le seul député
je n'ai plus d'inscrits sur l'article
nous allons passer au